sie wurde bedroht verfolgt und gestoppt
und jetzt musste sie sterben mehr als
zwei jahre lebte oder in ständiger
todesangst ex-mann valerie metzelte die
mutter von zwei kindern jetzt mit einer
langen klinge nieder mehrere stiche
trafen den hals
hier ist es passiert direkt vollgas
haustür namen der stalking terror ein
blutiges ende dort wo die ermordete 44
jährige eigentlich sicher und geborgen
sein sollte ihrem zuhause all das
martyrium begann schon auf dem täglichen
weg zur arbeit bild reporter sebastian
bringe traf ihre beste freundin jelena
am tatort in ibbenbüren sie sind oft
zusammenzuarbeiten gefahren dass das
auto offenbar mit wasser da alles
doch es blieb nicht beim psychoterror
aber erste fall war so dass er sie und
ihr kleinste sohn mit kettensäge
angegriffen zu hause im morgengrauen
lauerte der killer seiner aixtron ihrer
wohnung auf die tasche für den knast
soll er bereits gepackt haben denn die
tat war akribisch geplant er hat den
hund mitgenommen die nachbarn abgegeben
nachdem das geschehen hat und er hat so
wie man die sachen schon mitgenommen
weil er hat mehrmals geschrieben ich
bring dich um gegen knast aber
irgendwann komme ich aber dich gibts
nicht mehr schon er wollte einfach
möglich dass die totes das dass er sich
beruhigt und all das nur weil er olga
und dem gemeinsamen minderjährigen sohn
kein unterhalt sein wollte aber warum
griff die justiz nicht schon viel früher
ein was ich sagen kann ist dass
zumindest in diesem jahr kein aktuelles
ermittlungsverfahren gegen den
beschuldigten wegen vorwürfen zu
straftaten zum nachteil seiner frau
anhängig gewesen ist olga hatte offenbar
angst ihren peiniger anzuzeigen aber
auch ihre freundinnen durften nichts
sagen sie sagte ihm allein lassen wir es
berührt sich irgendwann das einfach nur
so jetzt bisschen genervt wegen training
wegen scheidung wegen geld wie
unterdrücken jetzt schuldgefühle dass
wir nichts unternommen haben aber man
kann leider jetzt nichts mehr machen
nach bild-informationen lernte olga
gerade einen neuen mann kennen ihr
mögliches todesurteil fest steht ihre
zwei kinder müssen jetzt ohne sie weiter
leben ja was für ein tragischer fall
nach all den jahren diese stalkings also
zwei jahre lang wurde sie gestoppt und
dann schlägt ihr ex mann zu und metzelt
sie so brutal nieder in diesem fall sind
so viele fragezeichen noch unterschätzen
auch die behörden häufig stalking noch
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen und
machen das mit einer langjährigen
kriminalkommissarin mit sand rahsegler
nämlich von der sicherheitsagentur es
und sos verzeihung schönen guten tag
frau ziegler
ja nehmen die behörden nach wie vor
solche stalking fälle wie in diesem fall
von olga oft nicht ernst immer noch
das ja dazu muss man zum einen wissen
dass in 70 prozent aller fälle viele
behördliche maßnahmen schon sehr wirksam
sind die polizei kann ja beispielsweise
eine wegweisung aussprechen oder ein
eine wegweisung aussprechen oder eine
gefährderansprache machen und in den
meisten fällen hilft das auch in den
fällen in denen sowas nicht hilft da
haben wir dann aber ein echtes problem
und da kommt es dann oft auf das
engagement von einzelnen polizisten und
polizistinnen an
was raten sie denn betroffenen frauen
die gestoppt werden und in genau so
einer situation sind nicht wissen wie
sie sich wehren sollen das vielleicht
auch schon gemerkt jetzt haben die
polizei informiert haben aber fühlen
dass diese bedrohung einfach überhaupt
nicht weggeht also es gibt ja dann auf
dem kontaktverbot und da man darf sich
nicht mehr ein problem oft halten sich
dann die person überhaupt nicht daran ja
richtig das ist tatsächlich ein problem
es ist vor allem sehr sehr wichtig dass
die betroffenen sich auf gar keinen fall
zurückziehen das heißt es ist sehr
wichtig weiterhin mindestens mit
wichtigen vertrauenspersonen in kontakt
zu bleiben oder eben mit den
sicherheitsbehörden oder auch mit
fachberatungsstellen im zweifel
vielleicht auch in einem frauenhaus zu
gehen also die bedrohung die von
stalking ausgeht ist immer ernst zu
nehmen das finde ich ganz wichtig
wichtig es auch gut zu dokumentieren und
ja auf alles immer auch gefasst sein das
heißt immer auch zeugen mit dabei haben
und niemals die gefahr von stalking zu
unterschätzen mein eindruck ist dass
stalking opfer ist immer noch wahnsinnig
schwer haben oder würden sie sagen in
den letzten jahren hat sich da so viel
getan mittlerweile hat der staat die
notwendigen maßnahmen ergriffen
es ist luft nach oben wir haben es hier
mit einem jahr mit einem delikt zu tun
was in den bereich der psychischen
gewalt hält dh wir können von außen oft
die gefahr und auch den schaden den es
bei den betroffenen hinterlässt nicht
sehen und das macht natürlich ist auch
sehr schwierig für den staat zu
verfolgen für die politik die richtigen
maßnahmen zu erlassen und oft auch für
die polizei wir haben aber definitiv
luft nach oben es ist beispielsweise
möglich auch mit fußfesseln für die
täter zu arbeiten um zu sehen wie sie
sich bewegen wo sie sich bewegen und
natürlich auch ein schutz für die
betroffenen zu bieten oder es würde auch
andere maßnahmen geben die aktuell noch
nicht umgesetzt werden
welche maßnahmen meinen sie da ganz
konkret was welche maßnahmen müssen
jetzt dringlich umgesetzt werden um
menschen besser vor stalkern zu schützen
zum einen würden wir ganz dringend
belastbarere zahlen benötigen aktuell
ist es so dass der zusammenhang zwischen
tötung versuchter tötung und stalking
überhaupt nicht statistisch erfasst wird
das wäre aufgabe der einzelnen polizeien
das in ihren seepolizei system einfach
statistisch zu passen damit wir
überhaupt eine grundlage haben um
politisch überhaupt zu diskutieren und
aus diesen zahlen würde sich definitiv
natürlich dann auch ergeben dass
polizeiliche und politische konzepte
noch mal neu überdacht werden können bzw
müssen also alleine polizei muss sehr
viel häufiger auch die gefahren von
doping fällen einschätzen und und
daneben auch richtig maßnahmen zur
verfügung haben mit denen sie auch
wirklich hilfreich was tun können das
sagt sandra stiegler stalking expertin
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch der gern